how does every dick you suck gives your
mom 10 more years oh my God I'll stop
[__] four dicks right now my mom's
gonna be like the next Buddha
[Music]
all right can I tell you guys the
craziest
only fan story that I've ever read yes
please do all right this was
um something that happened in Italy
between this woman named Carol the
meatballs yeah so
um there's a girl named Carol she's the
only fans Creator right she's dating a
guy named David and they don't end up
working out
but they're still in good terms and she
feels like he understands her so as she
continues to make content she asks him
to still be the person to assist with
the concert the stud [__] yeah
is that when you don't see a guy's face
well it's just kind of funny you're like
a benchwarmer like when people ask if
it's important I'm like no he'll stun
[__] like
a guy is like oh I'm sick I'm pregnant
whatever then we're like all right
boyfriend alert come in that happened to
me him and Angela White which was super
oh it's like a stand it's like a
stand-in or whatever you call it yeah
yeah yo your boyfriend is like living
he's like oh all right I guess so come
in
yeah me and Angela light like we
couldn't find a guy to [__] us on this
exact date for a scene and we like
already got everyone's booked we already
had the outfit the photographer we were
like boyfriend alert so he must be stunt
[__] okay so in a stunt car you have to
like show face or you don't have to it's
more like we just needed a penis because
I feel like girl and girl is kind of I'm
not the best at girl on girl because I
like like [__] you know I like you can't
be passionate about it yeah yeah I I'm
passionate about a girl sharing a cup
like just girl on girl like after a
while of us like doing we need a dick
somewhere yeah yeah let's do something
okay yeah so he's like he's okay yeah so
he's so she's got another boyfriend
already but he's still the guy that
helps with the content yeah so what
happens is she starts getting these like
really personal requests on her only
fans to do really specific things that
are not always like sexual view yeah
they're just like weird
um kind of like almost borderline
violent stuff oh oh not fun and then so
they're in the middle of filming this
one video where she has to have a hood
over her head should I be tied up Gotta
Have tape over her mouth and then the
request says oh tap tap the legs with a
hammer huh well that's a little a lot
that's a little a lot
and then it gets to like saying like oh
tap her stomach when the hammer and
eventually he bashes her in the head and
kills her um what By Request of of a
commenter that part was not in the
request from her ex-boyfriend stunt [__]
so then he ends up this guy can't play
video games you know that whole Theory
like a video you can do it in real life
this [__] is that dude yeah
wow that took like a twist it gets
classic Ryan's story it gets a million
times worse than that and it's being is
it live streamed or it's not live stream
it's a video request so it's being
recorded So then uh this guy's so does
somebody panics and wait why did he hit
her that hard not on purpose because he
hates her
what
so then to make matters worse he ends up
slitting her throat and then over the
next week takes her body apart piece by
piece the comments like hey chill bro we
didn't say to do all that
recording anymore but then he ends up
dumping it around town and in that city
in Italy and then for months he uses her
credit card and her phone to act like
she's still alive whoa wow that's a a
big oopsie daisies on his part and then
it turns out the whole time her only
fans he was the Prime customer making
all the requests oh
you're moving out of this guy what the
[__] it was him okay the the trial is
still going by the way I don't think it
needs to be a trial it's like dude
there's a video of you literally killing
someone no we don't need a child we need
a couple Netflix documentaries and some
[__] dramas crazy
it's so crazy only one fan only one fan
that's the name of the just only fan
only fan fans Not plural yeah you got to
cross out the S with a hammer so that's
her that's that's Carol sorry yeah
I want to see I didn't get to see her
that's Carol yeah okay
he looks like the type bro he does look
like a killing son of a [__] yeah no he
looks jealous you're [__] jealous
jealous [__] he's a yeah he's a silly
guy how do you know it's David and not
David or David so David
so dude jealous David that's so crazy I
guess that was a bummer yeah what kind
of just kidding news was that
he was like the worst story of your life
yeah it's the worst story for sure yeah
that is crazy right to find out that
it's that's [__] that's so dark dude
I know wait why why would he like make
those requests and get there and then
like do something so the the way that
the um the lawyers think of it is that
he was he was progressively making the
request more violent to actually kill
her yeah yeah yeah he didn't think I
guess like it didn't go exactly the way
a worm brain yeah yeah
I actually don't do custom requests on
my only fans because I feel like a lot
of my requests were like racist like I
would be like oh they want you to wear
like a hat like this like Kazumi can you
please wear this and go
they'll be like yo could you like [__]
on the Filipino flags and like whoa do
like some hella racist stuff and I'm
like first of all no to pooping second
of all no to anything with the Filipino
flag
you no what the [__] like you get it I'm
Asian TV I could take your racist
dollars I don't care but I won't do a
request I'll just do any normal stuff
what's the what's the highest price you
turn down for requests I feel like
there's like no price that'll make me
poop on camera but what about if it was
like for real a billion dollars
oh [__] on anything for a billion
dollars
like would they be like can you eat some
orange chicken okay I've done a lot of
happy ending massages I've done that
that's like well that's Multicultural
yeah yeah that's everyone but Asians
kind of like took the trophy for that
one I've done a bunch of school girl
stuff with like the the like the safe
that's normal yeah yeah well that's a
part of our normal Asian sexual
experiences we all wear it when we were
18 we were given this like school girl
outfit from Amazon and we all wear it
like at one point in our lives and you
know the blue one the blue and white
what I'm talking about they skipped it
it's the blue one with the white stripe
yeah okay classic one he's like I know I
know one billion dollars yeah one
billion the [__] come on maybe okay a
hundred thousand I'll [__] on anything
I'll [__] on my mom I don't care a
hundred thousand that's not so you [__]
on a Filipino flag would you start to
date where your mom dies wait what would
you suck a dick or your mom dies he suck
a dick before
[Laughter]
one million dicks two completion but
she's already like 85. one million dicks
okay ten dicks two completions that's a
couple of years
this epic you suck gives your mom 10
more years oh wow oh my God [__] four
dicks right now
my mom's gonna be like the next Buddha
I love my mom she's [__] awesome and
I'm [__] I'm going Full Throttle gay
for her yeah
come on I think like you know reasonable
trade like when she's getting old and I
really want her to be around like one
dick one year you know one dick one year
for every every dick I suck does it
matter the quality of dick I mean like
the size of the dick or like the person
the person like what if it's five like
smegma in it what if it's Five Guys what
if it's like five of us I would suck
Ryan's dick for [__] one day actually
for one day one more day guaranteed I
can add one day to your mom what if it's
the opposite what if for every [__]
you get your mom loses a month when I
receive
like when she passes you're like this is
my like you're the funeral like you
could have made it to October
[Music]
who's not gonna [__] live longer
you're like you have no [__] idea
what I did for you you ungrateful [__]
what if like every time you [__]
someone it like broke her bones
damn dude
I don't like their movies
already arranging a funeral right now
every time hey guys about my mom she's
[__] a wheelchair and she knows it's
you doing it she knows it's you stop
stop she shows up she's like Anthony my
FEMA that's even worse she's like that's
my boy
you'd be like keep going at least he's
[__] oh I gotta get a grandson
my sleep disc that's Anthony
all right